j'accueille eric morena
sous le ciel étoilé le coin gonflé de
bonheur les poissons-chats bancaire
mais rêver
m
et
violet
[Musique]
le nouveau nez menton
sur les ponts
simon
tu es la pudibonderie
m
[Musique]
dans
et le plus beau
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde en a parlé à
retrouver éric morena l'hidalgo est
toujours chanteur et où se produit-il
sur les terrasses de café au supermarché
devant ses amis et même au téléphone ils
habitent sur les bords de marne mais
c'est à liège en belgique que nous
l'avons retrouvée où il enregistre son
nouvel album dans cette lumière divine
tamisée par la nuit on vivait dans un
fils d'un certain fellini et il pleut
sur romain comme il pleut dans mon coeur
oh oui
[Musique]
alors elle est comment cette chanson
eric très belle chanson par rapport à
môssieur de son envergure
non
depuis le succès du bateau si la
carrière d'éric a pris en photo le
chanteur a conservé ses deux principales
qualités
humilité et modestie c'était un amoureux
et militer
faire mieux que le bateau s'est pas
pousser vient d'annoncer modestie très
belle chanson aujourd'hui éric l'ancien
missionnaires d'afrique est à nouveau
sur les routes
un de ses amis organisent une
manifestation bien aujourd'hui nous
allons à liège évidemment dans le plus
grand centre de la ville où se déroule
la semaine italienne
l'aïe a plein d'amis qui nous attendent
ceux des dégustations c'est la fête des
belles femmes en fin et tout est quoi un
centre culturel
pas vraiment le centre commercial entre
la mozzarella et le jambon de parme eric
morena et le roi de la fête
vous êtes en direct sur radio italien
c'est un honneur pour moi aller en plus
j'ai un fait
mitani c'est ma seconde patrie est-ce
qu'on leur connaît encore
et vous l'avez passée en discothèque pas
sûr
en bon vrp eric vérifier où son nouvel
album sera placée en tête de gondole
notre album sera donc
non seulement ici dans les rayons mais
où
fenêtres lampe devant elle
[Musique]
un vrai succès cette fête italienne
eric n'a pas changé de voie toujours le
fils spirituel de dario moreno et luis
mariano salue et coule dans le sang mais
continue de les titiller la corde vocale
[Musique]
j'ai maintenant la lumière se rallume
sur éric morena eric bonsoir bonsoir tu
es avec bienvenue dans tout le monde en
a parlé
vous n'êtes ni à saint-omer en 1951 vos
grands-parents tenait le plus grand
cinéma de saint-omer c'est ce qui vous a
donné le goût du spectacle certainement
alors vous passez votre adolescence à
lille est un vrai ch'ti vous parlait le
patois local
je ne comprends très bien vous ne parlez
pas disons que pour le métier j'ai vite
et de continuer à le pratiquer ce que
bon maintenant ressemblait trop à line
renaud
alors votre père était employé du crédit
du nord absolument votre mère était
démonstratrice au printemps de lille
elle faisait quoi comme démonstration
elle travaillait dans une maison je veux
pas citer la marque mais très célèbres
dont on parle beaucoup actuellement le
parfum l'oréal alors après un stage au
centre apostolique
vous êtes tenté par la vie de
missionnaire vous aviez la fois à ce
point j'avais la foi j'ai toujours deux
fois oui et je l'aurai toujours c'est
une chose qui me qui me force à
continuer à vivre c'est la foi alors
1972 entré au grand séminaire saint
sulpice d'issy les moulineaux et vous
songez à vous engager définitivement
dans une congrégation qui s'appelle les
pères spiritains quelles sont les règles
fiscales et à la pauvreté
ouais on la chasteté et l'humilité c'est
dur
je cesse être en plein paradoxe ouais
c'est très applicables oui quand on vit
au sein de la communauté mais alors vous
partez 2 en centrafrique
mais là vous avez une crise de la
vocation pourquoi c'est à dire qu'en
afrique
je me dis mais pourquoi eric et de quel
droit
veux-tu imposer sa religion à des
africains qui finalement sont très
sympas sont présume un corps rien
demandé certes mais qui n'ont rien
demandé voilà pourquoi pourrait leur
imposer une loi
donc j'ai une crise si vous voulez je
joue jour sur ce jeu de mot une crise de
foi mais non pas dans ma foi personnelle
vous voulez dans l'église bravo rentrée
au début des années 80 vous vous
installer à paris fait des petits
boulots êtes gardien de nuit
et puis vous vivez avec une femme qui
appelle patricia qui est follement
amoureuse de vous vous êtes plutôt
attiré par les garçons
mais vous avez avec elle une relation
platonique 10 ans et vous vous êtes
mariés civilement et patrice est
absolument d'ailleurs patricia fait
partie de ma vie aujourd'hui
absolument on s'aime beaucoup et notre
seul regret c'est de ne pas avoir eu
d'enfant
alors question ans garçons vous passez à
l'acte avec antoine donc [ __ ] barman
dans un cabaret de travestis
on est loin du séminaire doit quand même
un fruit des le goût du paradoxe et avec
des robes
il ya des regrets alors vous vous
installer en bien et là c'est le grand
amour avec antoine qui va durer 14 ans
oui alors antoine est formidable pour
vous il croit beaucoup à votre talent
ils vous poussent à vous inscrire dans
une association de chanteurs amateurs
qui fournit les maisons de retraite donc
vous partez chanter en métro un peu
partout il est vous pousse à prendre des
cours de chant enfin c'est quelqu'un qui
a été extrêmement bénéfique au départ
antoine il me lance
il me donne le courage parce que je suis
quand même décourager et il me dit fais
ceci fait cela alors en 1986 antoine
vous financent une cassette des mots et
vous commencez la tournée des maisons de
disques cassettes et c'est comme ça que
vous enregistrez oh mon bateau
oui qui a écrit cette chanson
c'est alexandre desplat qui est devenu
quelqu'un bon deux va plus présenter
cette chanson
me tombe dessus comme ça elle est
présentée par le chant tact et sel et il
me disait si tu es prêt à jouer le jeu
et bien si tu es prêt à jouer le
personnage extravagant
ce que je ne suis pas je suis quelqu'un
quand même à cette époque de très
réservé un jeu sort du séminaire voilà
et on me demande de faire le période
moreno pire est derrière moi si bien
qu'à un moment je perds même les les
je perds le contrôle du personnage que
même mon producteur me dit on fait de
trouve alors 7 500 un succès fou un
succès immédiat
il ya la mélodie évidemment qui est
excellente il ya votre look
et puis elle clip aussi sans le clip la
chanson n'aurait pas existé et surtout
alors là je tiens à le dire quand même
sans vous sans les médias oui oui parce
que c'est quand même visuel avant tout
alors vous retrouver rapidement au top
le single se vend à un million
d'exemplaires énorme ça dure et qu'en
même temps le succès luxe est arrivé
très vite non le bateau sort en février
87 et je suis nominé aux victoires de la
musique je fais l'olympia fin février 87
le clip est récompensée au lion d'argent
au festival de cannes en fait tout va
très très vite
comme m'a dit le producteur d'époque
comme un paquet de lessive
oui c'est le relations avec les médias
étaient bas non plus à l'époque et pas
de souci
après si jamais eu de problème avec les
médias c'est la télé qui m'a fait faut
pas l'oublier vais gagner de l'argent à
l'époque oui j'en ai brûlé beaucoup le
meilleur moment de cette époque c était
quoi eric l'olympia ouais chanter à
l'olympia dans l'ancien olympien est le
pire moment de cette époque c'était quoi
quand on commence à me demander après le
bateau de faire n'importe quoi le succès
du bateau y les ayant gonflé ils ont
voulu faire plus et finalement le
résultat j'ai fait des daubes à la suite
alors à l'époque vous mener grand train
avec tous les excès qui vont avec quoi
faire comporte grands appartements
belles voitures
les garçons à tout va et votre couple
avec antoine se disloque un petit peu à
ce moment là non c'est la cas vous vivez
toujours ensemble mais vous sortez
séparément c'est ça c'est tout le bien
que m'a fait antoine en réalité autant
moi je monte autant lui des à la cia le
mur de la solitude qui nous sépare alors
là vous sortez quelques 45 tours dans la
veine du bateau évidemment je suis le
torero de l'amour
ramon et pedro ça marche ça marche
honorablement mais ça n'est pas le
succès du bateau noria pas là mais je ne
sais pas le bateau c'est le même
compositeur mai
il n'y a pas de recette rhin pour un
tube c'est là que vous tombez amoureux
de doni oui alors là antoine sombre dans
la dépression ils sont et à picoler et
faire des excès sexuelle oui vous
apprendrez bientôt qu'il est malade du
sida
c'est là c'est là alors c'est là que
c'est ma période la plus noire parce que
je me culpabiliser
je me culpabiliser encore d'ailleurs à
ce jour parce que si j'avais eu un peu
plus de plomb dans la tête
antoine ne se serait pas égarer vers des
voies vers lesquels ils n'étaient pas
destinés et malheureusement ils tombent
malades gravement et à cette époque le
sida est foudroyant on perd beaucoup de
copains il ya toute une
il fait partie de la génération qu'on en
dise sacrifier et je le spi thalys chez
moi et je m'occupe de lui et là je me
retire et je m'occupe de lui jusqu'à la
fin vous survivez avec des galas de
province avec des animations de boîte de
nuit quoi pour faire tourner ben oui la
boutique wii et je n'ai pas du tout
envie de chanter d'ailleurs à cette
époque ce qui est terrible c'est que
j'ai remarqué que les amis qu'on a à
l'époque vous laisse tomber parce qu'il
à l'époque il disait à ea le sida
c'était encore tabou c'est là que pour
promouvoir l'idée du pacs c'est à dire
ça part d'une bonne idée au départ vous
vous prêter à un simulacre de mariage un
mariage gay bénie par un prêtre et vous
épousez denis toutes les caméras du pays
mais ça c'est une histoire de fou ça
j'ai fait ça pourquoi pas ouais un temps
j'étais un peu comme coluche et le luron
qui suis marié quoi c'était un gars et
chanter n'importe quoi ça voulait plus
rien dire ça fait de la peine à antoine
j'imagine antoine n'était plus lui-même
le sida avait déjà attaqué une partie de
son cerveau c'était devenu un bébé oui
nous avons des packs en ont ils disaient
simplement à mon bon qu'est ce qu'elle
va dire oui alors lorsqu'antoine moeurs
vous entrez évidemment dans une longue
période de dépression et là vous pensez
à vous retirer au monastère c'est à
retrouver finalement ce qu'avait été
votre vie d'une époque quand je rentre
dans la chambre de l'hôpital bichat
cette chambre vide mais son visage
reposé plus de souffrance ça c'est
extraordinaire
tout s'est effacé son visage et même
rose comme un enfant je recense 7 p
cette sérénité je dis ça y est il a
enfin la sérénité mais moi je ne l'est
pas moi je n'ai pas la sérénité et c'est
là que je pense vraiment à me retirer
arrêtez tout voilà il faut pas vous
l'avez pas fait avec
parce que j'aime chanter way we voulait
chanter du lyrique en plus j'aime
chanter ou l'ex quart pia oui ma vie
mais c'est ça ma véritable raison de
vivre finalement quand je fais mon
examen de conscience
qu'est ce que tu aimes et réguler dans
la vie mais c'est chanter le public le
contact avec le public
voilà c'est ça aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de cette époque du bateau
non non pas du tout je suis très content
d'avoir fait le bateau mais le bateau
est un piège parce que c'est à la fois
un cadeau à une grâce et c'est à la fois
un piège parce qu'on vous colle une
étiquette sur le front mon intelligence
à moi la finesse que je dois avoir dans
l'avenir
est ce que je vais faire est-ce que je
prépare c'est de préparer le public
parce que j'ai une bonne connivence et
que pumain c'est de préparer les gens à
aller vers une autre voie à me remettre
en danger et à ne pas m'installer dans
un succès déjà avec voilà vous êtes
rancunier par rapport à certaines
personnes de l'époque
non pas du tout il ya simplement une
chose que je pourrais dire qui pourrait
peut-être aider les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
j'en ai retiré une seule chose c'est que
votre plus proches amis peut-être votre
tuque prochainement ça c'est une
certitude
si c'était à refaire eric qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil
je ne referai pas le bateau je ne
referai pas le bateau je parle avec mon
coeur pour simplement pouvoir chanter ce
que j'ai envie de chanter lyrique de
l'opéra de ce lieu de venir car c'est là
sur scène oui et puis des belles choses
parce que j'étais très malheureux
pendant 24 ans à pouvoir aller à ce
qu'on me propose que des goûts de rio le
film est quelquefois bon voilà c'est
tout je suis sincère aujourd'hui vous
avez des projets dans le dans le lyrique
oui j'ai un album qui était qui et c'est
y qui est en boîte qui va sortir voilà
il y aura une grande surprise quand vous
allez mourir qu'elle voulait qu'on
écrive sur votre tombe comme épitaphe
il y en a une qui me plaît elle est pas
noir
enfin je suis devant toi merci eric
j'étais heureux de rallumer la lumière
sur vous merci merci tu pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou